[Music]
i've got everybody here i did have a
quick look before i think we've got
everybody here
um yes we are being uh live streamed and
it will be the audio recording will be
available on uh the council website
later as well
so it will be there for you
um any apologies anybody got to leave
early
conflicts of interest
right the last minutes
anyone got any questions around those
i'll move that they are accepted do i
have a seconder
thanks andrea
any discussion
right all those in favor raise your hand
or
mark
do whatever you
can do
um
those against
it's carried
all right we've actually got three
reputations
tonight
and uh so it's the next item on the
agenda we'll start with doug wethey from
woodin beach i'd also just like to say
that the information that was sent out
to board members
wasn't sent out to when it was sent out
anyhow
it actually relates to the long-term
submission the residents put in last
year to the council
um to ask for the funding to be brought
forward for the playground and toilet
renewal that was approved
so if you're reading it and thinking
well that sounds a bit strange the
funding is actually there for the next
financial year for this so
don't worry about that
i will
hand you over to doug
doug you've got about 10 minutes to
tell us what you think
well we um
i'll
i'll get um
anna to say something as well if that's
all right
the big thing is that the beach
playground uh needs upgrading uh with
some new stuff
uh and that's reflected to the toilet
area which is inadequate um when people
use when mothers and and children
use the playground they need uh really
ready access to the toilet facilities as
well and at the present time they're a
long way away
um so i've sent you pictures some of you
may have received the photographs
uh of the toilet facilities that we have
at the moment uh they're pretty
substandard
um and need upgrading
one of the things that came up in
talking to greg burns uh who's the chief
ranger at the tuatara trust
uh was that he would like to see the
toilet situated near the headquarters on
the hill
which would make it closer to the
playground
uh and also
people that are visiting the the rangers
headquarters and quite a lot of groups
now doing that they would be able to use
the toilet facilities there as well
we looked at the playground and
uh
they have an old disused toilet on the
hill
that's been disused and vandalized over
the years
that would make a really good base for a
flying fox
um so we would think that having a
flying fox there would be a nice
addition
uh also there's a
a jungle gym type thing that they've got
in oxford what's it called
a spider frame a spider frame we thought
would be great there and all of these
things can be done around the existing
playground
i think that there was a suggestion that
the whole thing needs to be
done away with and restarted but that
would take a lot of money and it's
absolutely not necessary we just need
some additions
um we don't need a whole new
uh taj mahal we just need something
that's uh
adequate one of the things that
the beach people would quite like to see
and anna might say something on this
would be half a basketball court like
they have in cairo
um the young people you could say
something about that yeah hi my name's
anna scotch thank you for having us here
tonight we really appreciate um just you
hearing our thoughts and hopefully
helping us out because um
we would love some help uh so currently
there's 50 plus kids in primary age at
woodyn beach and that is growing so
we've just got a
new development up the road for the
beach and possibly another one's
happening at woody and beach as well and
i've been here for 20 plus years and um
a lot of um no development down with the
toilets or the playground at all and um
with this amount of children down here
especially at the age like a majority of
boys
and a majority
[Music]
not on the streets but we've got a
beautiful you know environment for the
kids to grow up in but we just need to
also have somewhere for them to sort of
congregate and be and be safe um
basketball is a sport that's really up
and coming in a lot of people
at their property so we would love the
idea possibly of a half basketball port
down at the beach um
doug saying about the playground is how
it exists is good it's really good for
younger kids but yeah it'd be amazing to
be able to push it out a bit get a bit
more equipment there that um sort of
accommodates that older age group as
well and we do have a lot of people come
down and use the beach and the toilets
it does have an outdoor shower which is
great which would love to keep because
it's not
really inviting for people um
a lot of people come down and know that
there's a reserve there that they can
choose from
so it would be nice
um but the toilets just love to have an
upgrade just to make it a really you
know pleasant
um a pleasant environment for people to
be able to
work
you listening to us and thoughts about
it
out anna
that's that's about it
for such a long time as well i walk the
streets and we have a facebook page
i submitted a lot of ideas and i also
get a lot of people
um
would they like to see an upgrade and we
really
waiting out anna
anything
anything else doug
no i don't think so it's just that um
the council will probably have some
plans that they think might be
appropriate for us we just want to be
consulted and in the mix uh so that the
council don't come out with something
which is really not appropriate
um you know we
the residents out down here know what we
think we'd like
um and we just want to say uh
and speak to the right people uh so that
we don't have something imposed on us
that we don't really need
[Music]
i understand you have been talking to
tori yes yes we have yeah who is the
green space officer in charge of the the
project
so those channels of communication will
be important going forward
yes
i think she's doing a presentation to
you tonight and we're in a workshop
yeah later this evening and you'll be
able to listen into that later or listen
to it tomorrow if you want to
right thank you
that would be great
so open that up up to questions so yes
we are having a workshop with tori um
later on
um
and
not so much as to what's actually going
to be in the playground but just some
generalities before we do go out to
before she goes away to prepare a plan
and then actually you know we do consult
with the community so there is all that
process still still to happen so anybody
got any questions for john and anna
andrea
thank you very much for your
presentation so what i've taken from
that
um is a spider frame
a flying fox and your perfect magic wand
um a half basketball court and obviously
the toilets
to be refurbed is that correct
yes that's that's correct and uh perhaps
some smaller just beyond smaller
equipment for smaller children
i had a picture of a
something on a spring
um
but there was just an addition which is
not that important
okay
um
funny enough we've already been down
this road with
some of these items with other areas
toilets is the big dollar factor
they are extremely expensive
for council
and certainly not within our budget on
community board level
flying fox love them and i've been an
advocate for them for
another area as well
if we were to prioritize those four
there what would be the main thing for
you as a community if you couldn't have
all four what would be the priority
that's a tricky question um
you're the mum with the kids
yeah
i'm the mum with the teenage boys and
i'd say basketball court 100
but then there's also
the mums that sort of thing
we do currently have um they're slightly
dodgy it's
not
not high on safety
down there um and we've got a wooden
slide that probably needs a bit of a
railing put on it but um
yeah probably the spider or the flying
fox yeah i've just said two three there
all three um can we have all three yeah
of course of course
no
yeah that is a tricky question from the
for the age groups that's coming through
majority of them in the late primary
early
um high school so the the basketball
court kind of has
um
especially if it was concrete it would
be used for scooters it would probably
be used for tennis if it had a wall in
it it could have a multitude of uses if
we if it was planned
um
to have a multitude of uses which would
be really cool um but yeah i'm not sure
but whereas doug has some younger
grandkids down here so he'd probably be
playing a spider frame
yeah
may you yeah but um good question um
that's not really a clear answer sorry
andrea
any other questions from anyone
i just um i would talk to that
is um
i can't speak to a spider frame or i
can't speak to a half basketball court
but definitely um a flying fox has been
a part of our
as part as far as costings for another
area
um and i
it does make me smile that the toilets
weren't a priority
oh no they are a priority sorry i
thought you mean um just for the
playground yeah
can i interrupt here the toilets are
actually funded
under the ltp as is the playground
renewal so
it's a playground refresh so that is not
an issue so the toilets yeah
thank god
okay um
so i guess from my point of perspective
i love that you've actually made the
effort to come to us for this i have no
costings or number wise as far as spider
frame or a half basketball court
only thing i would ask for for staff
would be to come back to us with costing
so we can actually evaluate to see what
we were looking at
as far as an investment to the area
um but i totally agree with you that
anything that can benefit our children
and families because of the cognitive
getting them out of the of their homes
and off the ipads and all of the devices
totally get that being a mother as well
um but we would need to seek um
some consult from the staff at council
as far as costings for that spider frame
and also for a half basketball court and
then if permission we can come back to
you then you come back we can come back
to you
and then discuss this further but we
need the facts before we could make any
um support of any one thing from my
perspective as a board member so
but i thank you
thank you
so that that will be part of the
workshop tori will will go through the
process that will follow and yes we do
always get the costings and and
everything so
that won't be an issue
so thank you very much doug and anna
thank you very much for all the work
that you have done and
your ltp submission last year was great
and you got the result so
congratulations
and
we thank you thank the board too for
their interest thank you
so
you can um
you can disappear if you like because it
will be later in the meeting when we do
have a workshop with tori um you can
listen to it live
later on or um
um tomorrow
it'll be online
thank you very much
thank you board members
thank you very much for your time
appreciate it
thank you
so we've got a presentation now we'll go
with with max warren who is wants to
talk to us about the waikoku beach
head shout about
max are you there yeah i'm here hi
everyone um
yeah you've obviously read the report um
hopefully um
my i guess my my two cents is
um
[Music]
reading the report i think
that this right decision has been made
to
to plan to
um remove it
um
however i think the time frames that are
mentioned are a bit extreme given that
the amount that the hedge grows every
every year um well i've been on this
site
not not long um admittedly only not two
and a half years now but i've been in
waikaku basically all my life um
it
especially down mine which is the
southern end of park terrace it is um
it's getting out of control in terms of
being able to trim it every year i don't
think and which is why i guess it hasn't
been trimmed i don't think there's a
there's a machine big enough to actually
trim the top and sides of it um
successfully like can be done i guess
further towards the
the north um
so my concern with the report was that
it would be done in 2025 or 2024 which
is another two
two and a half years
um
and each year it's you know it's growing
a meter every way as it does
um
and that's my main concern really um
also i guess the tender cost of of doing
it which seems quite high i mean i'm i'm
not a arborist
admittedly um but
i think yeah if you leave it for another
couple of years it's obviously going to
expand in size by
you know a third
and therefore the price is going to go
up again um
and i guess
based on what i talked who i talked to
in the community and and everyone around
here the vast ma well not vast majority
obviously based on your report um which
was i think 58 positive
for removal um
yeah the people i talk to that live in
the area are keen to have it removed
just because
i mean it's it's not great for school
kids walking walking down to the bus um
they're walking on one side of the road
like my kids who's my kid oliver i've
got a two-year-old who we walk down to
the bus with another couple of girls
from
um pine avenue
it just it because it encroaches on the
road it is it is quite sort of you know
you've got to walk on one side if you've
got cyclists or skateboarders
you're all focused on one side of the
road
um
and if it was removed and replaced with
natives which i think was in the plan
um
i think it would just be a far more sort
of
an environment or akin to the community
with what's the wetlands there
um it's not an invasive macrocarpa hedge
which
i
my opinion is that macrocoppers sort of
belong in the hinterland rather than a
wetland at the beach um it should be
natives
um
and i feel for ruth down on the corners
an elderly lady
with
with it just growing basically consuming
her her yard and she's talked to me
numerous times
about getting removed but obviously yeah
we've got to all go through this process
and everyone has their
has their thoughts and their say on it
um and yeah i'm having mine now
that's probably it from me um
yeah
thank you max for for a um submitting
your feedback because i know you did
which is great and for taking the time
you know to present tonight um which is
is really good and i know you you asked
me last year
you know when when it was going to be
and if you could um present so
um it is good that we have got that
so has anybody got any questions for max
[Music]
i've got one max how much shelter do you
think it provides for the houses along
there
not a lot to be honest i mean i'm a bit
of a weather nerd um
i surf a lot and i've got a weather
forecasting little
thing with the dial and um it tells me
what way the wind direction is we don't
get a lot of westerlies here which
is evident i mean we get north westers
and we get sources and norwesters blow
more north in makuku and southwest just
by more south we don't actually get a
wind that comes directly from the west
which this thing shelters us from
um
and most of the properties down here
have a decent fence and then trees
anyway and and even in the long term
you know trees will grow up in a couple
of years anyway just not to the height
of this thing because
what i see in this thing i remember i
lived in new brighton for a while and
the the microcarp is that that lime
marine parade down by the north beach
surf club which
which is just um
they've got away obviously and
they are they're so big and i think this
is what i sort of see this happening i
mean i look out my window now and it's
it's at least 12 meters high at on the
corner of ruth's place um
[Music]
yeah
i
it will it obviously would provide
shoulder given a sickness and it's in
its size but
i think
the benefits of removing it would far
outweigh the shelter that we get because
i mean most of the time it's a
necessarily right
true any other questions from anyone
has the heck did you have any costing
about the removal
it's in the report john
i read i read that but i'm just
wondering
you know what what impact does
those costumes have
well i think it was at twenty thousand
dollars to to trim every year when
remove was a hundred thousand plus
whatever else you're planting so
i mean five years time you're you're
already
you're at zero
andrea i thought you reported
andrea
got it um the unfortunate thing is it's
actually 85k
above the current budget
so it's quite a significant amount of
money and max i totally agree with you
as well um the challenge we have with
when it goes that far above
is it really needs to be recognized in
the ldp
uh which is not what you want to hear
and i know what you're saying
because 2024 is a long time out and
that's when we're projecting that it
could potentially happen for you but i i
totally concur that
this is you want to get it done
urgently more urgently than 2024.
um
only thing for me is i need to seek
advice and we've got that from council
that they
agreed so that they could remove it
and that um we would look at finding the
funds to actually cover it
and that's where i feel comfortable with
that at that point 85k unfortunately is
an ex significant amount of money yeah
unless we win lotto but i don't think
council can apply for a lotto ticket um
so
um but recognize what you're saying and
i feel sorry for what you're saying for
the neighbor down the road as well but i
guess this is the restraint we have and
it is a significant amount of money
above where they are currently our
budget at the moment
um but i certainly would support and
we'll come to that um that we definitely
review it
but it would need to have review of
where we can actually gain that money
from
would it be worth considering removing
um like sections of it that that have
that obviously down mind south side it's
it's twice as large as it is on the
north um whether you could do it in
segments because
i honestly think it's going to get
well the longer you leave it the larger
it gets and obviously the more money you
spend um
yeah yeah i i completely understand
where you're coming from i mean it's an
absorbent amount of money i mean
yeah i'd like to tender for it but i
don't think enough chainsaw
thanks max that's one question we can
actually either
now does anybody ask have any other
questions
emphasis on questions
but thank you very much max for
you know participating in this if you
want to stay online uh we'll hear from
joe kane next who's also going to do um
as a deputation and then we will have
the item on the waikoku beach hedge so
if you actually want to stay online
you'll be able to to to listen to it
live all right thank you
thanks max yes
welcome joe
can you hear me
we can thanks joe right nothing went
well i'm
i'm across the road from max
and i wrote down what's on a hedge i can
tell you what this has been a very
painful process and i'm looking at
andrew i'm going andrew imagine from
your place having something over 12 foot
in front of your place and knowing
beyond that is the southern alps and the
estuary and what have you so i've lived
here over 30 years now
and i can tell you when i used to walk
past that hedge it was just up past my
shoulder so i dispute that it's got some
history
um and i'm very very unhappy with the
process really unhappy and i'll tell you
why because i kicked this off with the
roading team and we went a long way with
the roading team and they kicked it to
the
rec team and then when it got held up
with the wreck team because the roading
wanted to go back to about a footpath it
was never about a footpath it was about
a hedge that has grown huge inside that
shades a road and therefore shades all
of the houses on the inside not just the
ones directly opposite i'm one two three
back and i lose the sun in the middle of
winter at three a.m ruth ruth doesn't
get the sun
for most of the from the lunch time
right through till about four when it
drops over the other side so this is
about a a health and well-being good
thing as well
the hedge is dark it is too tall it has
got rubbish underneath it i've never
seen a kid play in that hedge for years
and years and years and actually if you
tried to get through it you'd find it's
not very nice i did remove the shopping
charlie that without it so the process
has really irritated me in this and only
three weeks ago or a couple of weeks ago
when i rang to say
was this report finally going after
being mucked around with these reports i
was given an expectation
to some questions i asked that this was
already almost a done deal that and so
much so that i talked about how quickly
could a contract could we have the
benefits of this and i and i'm not i'm
not that stupid i can be silly but i'm
not that stupid that i now feel really
resentful that i've missed putting into
the annual plan about this because i was
given an expectation
that this was
just a matter of um
the process of getting it through
council when i read the report to find
2024 so it'd be five years since this
project was started myself going to
roading including a community
consultation
expectation most of the people along
here that said no have actually changed
their mind
once they actually saw how it was
getting taller and then we talked again
about
um the shading effect on their
properties especially in the wonder
because it had the consultation was done
in the middle of the summer and it's not
quite such a problem because the sun
sets way further along so i'm i'm not
really i'm not actually happy the
footpath we talked about
take it out we can once the hedge is
removed we can possibly take some
driftwood and put a beach trail type
thing along there until the footpath
comes in
as i said the amenity is behind the head
there are wetlands there are southern
alps there's rural things this is an
unsustainable hedge now from from the
end that i look out which i can see out
through my window now well my tape
measure didn't i couldn't get it up that
high i measured the width the width is
only eight meters down our end and i
agree with max
that perhaps you can do the end causing
the most grief where everyone
um is in problem
you know having the problem with it and
especially when the winter and i want
you to think about what that means when
the winter comes at three o'clock the
sun is gone from your property
it goes
it's because it is so hot and even when
they trimmed it last time they trimmed
it at 10 foot and i i think max is right
i think that's as high as their reach is
going so i think we're in a big trouble
i am really unhappy
that i in good faith have taken part in
this process and i read a report that
talks about 2024
because that was never the expectation
when we consulted on this was never the
expectation from anyone in the community
and i'm not i'm not just going to lie
down sure it's a lot of money so let's
try and find some ways that we can get
this down it seems a lot of money for a
hitch
um and then i'll i could put to you
you're going you're going into a
consultation process shortly about more
things that y cookie beach wants well i
put it to you that waikoku beach is
spoiled for recreation amenity type
stuff we have a lot of stuff that we get
free the beach the ocean the trees the
forest bike things this is a a
maintenance issue long-standing
unsustainable and it really caused me to
think
that for the next three years you'll
have to trim this hedge back off the
road because it's now
and we asked we actually asked it not to
be trimmed last year so we could save
the money
and and now we get told to wait for
2024.
so i had really high expectations and i
feel really let down when i when i saw
that piece of the report and i felt
worse because i didn't bother putting in
a submission i would have put in a
submission and i would have done a
little bit more work to go and gather
the people that had originally said
oh no we think we'll lose our privacy we
think we this have all the three down
the far end and the two down here have
all changed their mind going actually
it's a pain in their butt so
i'm not happy about the process to be
honest glad that you've got the report
glad that you can see the costs the
costs are the costs but the cost to us
where we live here
is i would rather see the amenity values
that i think that everybody would enjoy
along here instead of being dark
and and actually very icy in some how do
i know it's icy because i've slipped on
it twice i've walked along there
i slipped once
once really badly and the kids have to
walk it's dark
it's not about a footpath it's about a
hedge that has got out of control and
needs to be gone sooner rather than
later why would you keep maintaining it
when you're if the decision which i
absolutely agree it goes down i don't
agree about the time frame
as an aside i don't know whether there's
any money left in the wake beach
freeholding account simon mark and you
might be able to find it there was money
in the freeholding account that could
only be used at waikoki uh beach
when i left the council there was still
a hundred and ten thousand dollars on it
and so
maybe someone could go and find if all
that money's been used
but i'd be if you're not keen on 85
let's try and look at um
40 this year 40 the next year and get it
down get half and half
so thank you i'm really glad it's here
but i'm really not happy about the time
frame i feel very let down and i think
when i go down and talk to people in the
community they're going to look at me
like i've got two heads because i skip
along and go yeah it's really great the
staff are on board
um and it can we can if it goes through
and through council we can probably get
it down this winter
door
navy
so pretty disappointing really
thank you joe
um
yeah i mean you've you've put your views
out very well and um
which is good for us to actually hear um
so i would open it up to questions and i
would remind people that it is actually
questions please
um anybody got any questions for
it joe look like it just
so i would say again thank you very much
for putting your views
it is appreciated because we do need to
hear from the community so it is
appreciated we will move to that report
next so if you want to stay around you
will you can hear what we come out with
so
thanks everyone thanks for listening
thank you
we don't have any adjourned business so
i will move to the first report which is
the future of the shout about hedge
so grant
we've got grant mccloud is going to take
that one i do believe
this is a green space night tonight i've
decided
uh yep no you're getting this grant not
grant uh reboot um
joe's uh comments uh not lost on me i
think it's uh very fair in terms of what
she was saying um
you'll see from the report that actually
what's kind of come out of that is that
the community is relatively supportive
of us taking the hedge down
um really one of the key issues that
we've got with this project is the
timing
i agree with what joe and max are saying
as well there's every chance the green
space can go back out and actually get
this uh re-tended or re-priced
um
we could also work with the local
community as well in terms of looking at
the the timing of this in terms of what
it is that we actually um do and whether
or not there's a more pressing section
of the hedge that needs to be looked at
before any other
um what i would say is that in terms of
replanting um
we're probably going to lose this season
um so any planting plan that we need to
do i'd really like us to actually do
that with the community again
um in terms of looking at what it is
that we might actually do just in terms
of a simple cross-section for that for
that area because it's relatively quite
long
as the submitters as the deputizers have
said as well
the hedges have actually grown over a
period of time and as we know 10 years
isn't actually that long
these days uh and it's not long in the
lifespan of a tree or a hedge either so
i mean even if we go and put some
uh native planting in there what we'd
quite like to do is make sure that we do
leave some space for
uh if we're not gonna have a pathway at
least leave some space for people to
actually be able to meander down that
side of things
you will have heard from max
pointing out the fact that everybody
goes on to the other side and you can
see from the photo in the report as well
that's
a little bit space limited on the other
side as well once people are parking
their vehicles in there
so look i'll i don't doubt that with two
deputizes
rather than hearing me kind of talk too
much about the report you're probably
boosting with questions
so i'll leave it over to you to guide
the conversation from here
the questions anybody for
for grant
sorry andrew yep sorry i'm sorry you
took me through the time
grant the obvious question is um
uh
ways and means to fund the room the
removal of the hedge
as quickly as possible
you know so that's because that's the
million dollar question you can see from
in my my my view it's um
the majority are supportive of it
there's enough logic to it and whatnot
but uh but um clearly you ain't got a
yeah there's no um established budget
for it
are there um
can you see
ways that um that
the hedge could be removed
um in whole or part more quickly than
what the
on the other
paper implies with 2024 long-term plan
yes
and why i'm saying yes is that i think
that we could look at some options to
actually make things better down there
without just spending
one of the concerns that i have is that
over the next two or three years in
essence what we'd be doing is going and
maintaining that edge twice
um now because this report's taken quite
a while to get to the board post the
in fact it's almost a year
um
since we consulted with the community
that hedge has grown quite significantly
so any work that we do to it now quite
rightly as max and joe pointed out is
going to be more expensive anyway um we
didn't do any uh
trimming last year because of the the
request from the community to say hey
well can you save it so that we can put
it towards the removal if that's what
we end up doing so there's still some
funding available there operationally
for that
obviously we'd be needing to do it
within another
12 months anyway from the original time
period of july last year
so there is some funding there
the reality is we are
[Music]
we are running quite um
tight in terms of our opex because that
is uh rates generated
um however if this was to become a
priority for the winning theft and
community board then really that's kind
of what this report is about for them to
i guess push that back to staff and
maybe even refer it up to council as
well
thanks right phillip bensandra and then
john
ah thanks grant
presumably there is provision to ask the
council if this funding could be brought
forward
by one or two years
there is always that mechanism yes that
would require council approval the other
thing i wondered
in terms of the recommendations
whether if the board was in agreement
that the board could express its
preference
that this work be
carried out in 2223
um
if at all possible
so that could be true
yes
no there's probably a question for the
board they may like to uh think about
and i'd like to thank joe and max for
coming along and um
giving us their views i think it's very
persuasive to hear from people
sandra thank you
thank you just to clarify how much money
is
is in the budget already for this hedge
i mean if it was some
not trimmed um last
financial year is that my understanding
there's 20 000
sitting there and the budget you've
budgeted another 10 to 15 000. so
there's something like
is there 35 000 up until june
no so theoretically we didn't spend 20
we didn't spend the 20 000 last um last
season
so that's the current year still
yeah
so there's only 20 000
and it would potentially have been
another trim next financial year
so going into
just after winter like end of june 30th
there's another 10 or 15 000. so yeah
because realistically we would have
looked to
done the original cut last year in july
and then we would have looked to
probably
april to july next year to do the next
cut
so rather than 85 000 if you're just
looking at the hedge
there's potentially
you need 50 000 more or less because
you've got 20 000 that you didn't lose
last year and another
15 10 to 15 000 that you'd you would
already have in the budget that we're
considering
um submissions on you know next next
month
i i think my mess would support that
yeah okay so it's a bit more
i um and just asking are there any other
funds that um i mean is it a safety
issue
um it seems that the community does
think it's a potentially a safety issue
is um does that mean there is any funds
from any other magic account
yeah no um
[Music]
we've
it's not been confirmed that it's a
safety issue from uh the roading team
um and as far as fins goes it's not
something that they would look to put
money towards
okay well the
the um
the remedy is a submission to um bring
bring funding forward um
i guess um failing all other avenues
thank you
thanks sandra john can i just let simon
have um he's got something to say which
might actually help us along the way
hopefully simon
i hope so um so
look
uh i know the uh submitters and
particularly joe or sorry the
presenters particularly joe being
concerned that they might have missed
their opportunity
um but this report's been some time in
the making
um and so the issue predates the
consultation period so
from my point of view it's quite
legitimate uh should the board be minded
to make a recommendation to the council
to get this
hedge removed in the 2223 year
that grant could bring a report to the
deliberations meeting for the annual
plan
with options to fund
phase
accordingly to to make that happen
um consistent with the
direction of the consultation and the um
deputations tonight
should you pass that
um
uh uh make a recommendation to the
council to for it to consider as part of
its 2223
annual plan allocating funding
uh to enable this to happen uh in that
financial year
thanks simon
john did you have a question
[Music]
grant um i noticed
when i read your report
you made a mention about firewood take
from the heads
is that correct
we can do that if the contractor who
does it um agrees to that uh otherwise
generally we would look to mulch and
reuse um but there are instances we've
just done at melton park actually where
uh some of it was turned into firewood
which actually turned it to a cost
recovery for us
i was just thinking over the hedge of
that size
and proportions
there'd be a tremendous amount of
firewood come out of it
and that could offset the cost of
actually removal
and and that's a really fair point john
we could actually get a contractor who
was willing to do the work to look into
that and see what um viable wood there
would be within there
thanks thanks that i would actually like
to move something
i would like to move a that we receive
the report
b that we approve the removal
um
i'll come back to c
d that we note the delegations that sits
with us
but e what i would like to replace with
that
we recommend that
green space
go to council
to ask council to consider funding
uh removal of the hedge in the 20
to 23 year
recognizing that it is a late request to
the annual plan but there is reasons
for that but it is late so we would
actually like
to see that happening in the 22-23
year
um
i would also move
so that would be replacing e
note if f's fine and g removing the
words at the end of in 2024
2025 which would make it notes that the
hedge would be maintained at health and
safety levels until it's removable i
think that should probably stay in there
regarding the planting plan i actually
agree with with with grant and i i think
a a
a more detailed concept plan should be
prepared for planting to come back to
the community board and the community
so i would move that to replace
c
do i have a seconder for that
yeah i'll sign it
who's that mark thank you
that's why it's hard but i can't see you
uh right my reasoning for this is
because
um the cost of trimming the hedges high
and ongoing trimming will you know will
stay high um it needs a good trim now i
was down there this afternoon and it
needs a heck of a good trim now so that
would be at least twenty thousand
dollars i would imagine
um
then it would need another trim
you know probably you know late 23 into
in into 24.
so again as sandra said you've already
you know this money's already been being
spent
um
so you'd have 35 000
spent on trimming it
need to then remove it
um in some ways it's better to bite the
bullet now
and do it
um
and if it's not removed those trimming
costs just carry on and on and on
um you know replacing it with native
planting will it's going to provide a
habitat and
food supply for native birds and provide
shelter so it will actually provide a
shout about for the houses as well
um
without
that shading aspect and it does i was
down there would have been after three
this afternoon and the it was pretty it
was getting pretty shaded then
um
so yeah i wasn't um
surprised at that one
andrew have you got something you want
to say
no sir it was mark but seconded sorry
mark
um no i just think it makes sense to not
waste the money on trimming it but i'm
trying to
bring forward i
would like to see that the
planting concept plan if the removal
gets approved or gets bought for that
the planting plan follows not far
after you know
hello
uh thank thanks madam chair could you
just read out the
amended e
so e was the yep um
recommend that um
green space so
ask that green space ask council to
consider bringing the funding
uh for the removal of the hedge
forward and the next annual plan to the
22-23 financial year
um
recognizing
that it is a late request under the
annual plan but there are reasons for
that
i just wondered with your approval and
the meeting whether we could use the
word requests
request yeah um
which might be more appropriate
yep
i'm happy with that mark are you happy
with that
yep
i mean that
so grant has suggested we could also
look at putting
a time
time frame
on getting the landscape plan back to
the community board so that we can then
engage with the community
which may well be a wise idea as well
what do you think would be a fair time
frame grant considering workloads
um look i'd think given that we've
already done some work uh
you know there's three months to go
before the end of the financial year i
would expect it to come to your july or
august meeting
because we then still have to consult
afterwards so i think you know two
months is probably enough
so we can we could build that into c as
well
so that we have um
requested um a detailed concept plan
for planting for native planting to come
to the community board
in
you know by august this year
is that all right with you mark his
secondary
yep
any other comments from anyone
andrea
um i think grant's comment about putting
it to community but i do challenge when
we've already gone out to the community
already
is this just delaying inevitable
because we've already been out to the
community already and they've stated
what they want
so i'm very conscious that we can go
back and forth with community
consultations but really i think it's
pretty evident on what the community
wants and that's my personal opinion
thank you it's just
planting
the native plants
but that's already been noted here with
the report we've received back
i just don't see the merit of going back
to community again
for another time when we actually have
it pretty clear what they are wanting
from us because we've got the we've
actually had that already that
consultation
that's just how i feel thank you shana
i don't think the consultation actually
included what would be planted in its
place i'm not sure simon
[Applause]
that was my um
point uh madam chair that
i don't think there was an intent to go
back to the community about relitigating
the removal
um but that a concept design for what
would happen in its place um would be
made available for feedback and i think
that's the sentiment that
andrea is uh i you know it won't
reopen the issue but it furthers
implementing the
um
the
direction of travel to agree tonight
okay i'm actually just reading the
consultation document that went out and
it says if removal of the hedge is
preferred by the community and approved
by the community board options on
whether to replant a new shout about or
leave it unplanted will be determined in
the future
and would be subject to availability of
funding
we would also need to talk to nearby
property owners if free planting was
considered in the future it may be more
appropriate to replant an alternative
species species in a slightly different
location
so it could well be something that we
probably should
you know talk to the community
uh
about
um
of
and looking at do we leave a pedestrian
strip
uh and do something i mean joe actually
had a very interesting idea around a
driftwood sort of path
because having been there this afternoon
one of the problems i would see is is
actually
at the moment everybody parks on the
other side of the road as you can see in
the photo in the report but that hedge
is removed and there is a strip left
there a car is going to start parking
over it
so you know looking at concepts like
that and and joe's thought of perhaps
you know
laying out some driftwood to um along
there to denote a walking path
um
would deter cars from parking along
there
i don't know
my challenge to that shona is appreciate
what joe has said
but
unfortunately
after two terms i can appreciate how
action can be slowed down with community
consultation um grant i asked you or
even to um simon as a river of time
where you go back to the community and
say
we can go back to your community
consultation but this is where we're
seeing it at and if you're you know what
i mean like if we're happy to proceed
with this or asking the question do you
want a community consultation
i'm just trying to avoid the time
because i know how these things can drag
on that's all i'm getting at that's what
i'm getting at because time seems to be
the pressing thing with the community
thank you
look i certainly appreciate the concern
um
i guess we've seen some pretty
passionate
presentation tonight about this issue
i'm imagining that there will be views
about the finer details of what happens
in place of the hedge
and i just think we need to be attuned
to that possibility
andrea and
i think grant will be keen to
um complete that the process to a point
where removal and
replacement
is um
is
done as rapidly as possible bearing in
mind that if there's to be replanting
then there's a new season coming up and
uh those kinds of considerations but
grant you may have some other comments
um yeah look i appreciate the
the comment uh
in terms of community engagement this
one wouldn't need to be um too long
because realistically in
in terms of replanting it or what the
replanting plan might look like
we do already have the bones of that
within the report
the only thing that we don't have at the
moment is community endorsement to put
that particular kind of planting in
um however that could actually be done
relatively promptly probably within two
week window with a decent engagement
plan
we know that we've got the direct
neighbors across the road and people
already engaged in this
we've got two of them on the call here
tonight so it wouldn't be difficult for
us to get information in front of people
and say
you know we can ratify this at the same
time as writing a shadow report so that
once we get all of that feedback in we
can actually put that up to the
community board because really that
would just be a case of confirming
uh the planting style or the planting
species that we'd be looking at and we
could then just make sure that the
community has had that final tick
in terms of what it is that we go and
put in there
um yes it would always save green space
time if we win
just planted things but quite frankly
that doesn't lead to good outcomes for
us longer term because we need the
community to buy into these things
only that thumbs up for grant and i
thank both him and um simon for
listening
um obviously to my mirror of what i was
trying to get across and totally respect
what they're saying and i love to hear
the word promptly
which is which is very foreign i know
when it comes to local government
um but um but thank you very much for
listening and i appreciate i appreciate
your um argument so thank you thank you
anything else from anybody um yeah i
like your idea of um
putting some driftwood down the side of
the path
i was wondering whether in actual fact
there could be
some um
branches resurrected from the hedge
that could be used to macrocarp is
fairly
so you know a
fairly durable timber
so there might be enough
um timber coming out of the hatch it
could add to the path
there's all sorts of things we could do
and i think we'll leave that to green
space to look at the options of you know
how we do
i just want to know we have to put no
parking lines which is probably not
you know the ideal situation if we can
actually prevent some other way people
parking along there
yeah
so there's nothing else i'll put that to
the vote
does everybody understand the motion
tia have you got it recorded okay
yep oh
it has been seconded john i'll just put
that to the boat all those in favor say
aye
raise your
hand thanks andrea see that one um those
against
that's carried
thank you very much grunt for
for giving us the report and thank you
again to max and um
who's still there and joe who are still
there
we will try and get
a solution
we will do our very best
thank you very much
thank you
thanks guys
thanks everybody right the next report
is i do believe on
my cookie beach as well martin
yes martin's there hi martin hi how are
you can you hear me okay
can you hear me all right yeah cool
everybody okay
does everybody meet martin
i'm not sure
no i think yourself martin yeah hi my
name's uh martin mcgregor so i've been
uh at waimea district council now for
about eight weeks or so um
and so this is my first community board
meeting and uh yeah it's great to meet
everybody um i'm a local resident so
i've lived in the wymac uh for about
about six years but i've been commuting
for the last uh 13 years working for the
christchurch city council so um so now
i've i've jumped ship and and it's great
to work local
with you guys so yeah very good to meet
you
you've seen the light go
absolutely absolutely
yeah awesome thank you um so yeah thank
you uh for the opportunity um so
tonight's report is um regarding the
spatial planning at the
cuckoo
reserve this is very much
community driven we've been approached
by a number of groups seeking
space or access to the reserve to for a
number of initiatives be it a pump track
or a volleyball net or
a club rooms for the north side board
riders
we also have in addition to that the
surf club who are considering
plans for their building going forward
so in terms of
addressing these needs or desires
efficiently um the best approach
we decided working with with andrew and
shona is to create a spatial plan for
the reserve to take all of this into
account so
what i'm seeking from the board here
tonight is
an endorsement or support i guess of the
action plan that was attached to the
report
and then also
approval to do an initial consultation
and and the basis of that initial
consultation is to uh just canvas the
community to make sure that we've got
everything um before we uh partake in on
this journey um and that there's nothing
else out there that people would like to
be considered or factored into into this
process so
with that i'll take the report as read
but uh happy to answer some questions
thanks martial any questions from anyone
you must have done a very good report
there will be plenty of opportunities
down the track to discuss this yeah yeah
angry
if i may i this whole process um that
doesn't matter in times like well i
can't say and i just confide but i
understand ask me questions now i just
uh madam chair i just want to clarify
um that yeah shona and i have been
involved in this and um you know
uh totally supportive of this um way
forward i think it's a great thing to be
doing too and getting so totally
supportive of the paper here i don't
actually have any questions
now i
do have one would it be made extremely
clear in the communications that go out
to the community
around the
that there is no funding
sitting in behind this um because i
don't want to get
expectations up
that a b and c are going to happen um
yeah that would be
yeah i really want those i don't want
expectations raised from the community
that
oh we're going to get this we're going
to get there and the council is going to
pay for it yeah yeah i think certainly
that that concern is shared by staff
also and uh when we had an initial
meeting just last week with our
consultation team uh we certainly raised
that as a risk so yeah absolutely
they'll be factored in
thanks martin simon
um madam cheered look um from a
management team point of view i guess
that was the one issue about this
exercise and i'm not at all
um taken away from the initiative
but expect as soon as we do something
some planning then that builds
expectations so
apart from the fact that there's no
budget
uh it may be if there was um
uh guys grant martin explanatory
information about the sorts of things
that council does
fund
and the sorts of things that it doesn't
um because uh that that might help
people queue
when they start getting creative no
disrespect to them
about what is practical realistic
fundable and what isn't so that might be
um a little bit of additional
information that would help
manage expectations to a good result the
last thing of course we want is a
fantastic ambitious plan
uh that will not be realized for 20
years
thanks simon grant grant and then andrew
oh sorry sorry andrew um i just wanted
to reiterate uh just a point there to
simon all of the ideas that have come
forward for this spatial plan have
actually come forward from the community
um and they've all come forward from the
community wanting to fund them as well
what the the main reason that we've
decided to go with this is that we
couldn't individually work with each of
those groups
um in isolation from the community and
kind of give away some of the the
limited space that we've actually got
within the reserves in waikoku
and we also didn't want to take those
groups too far down the track without
actually communicating with the
community to see if they even wanted
additional
assets and resources actually put onto
some of these reserves
one of the other key things in here as
well is that we are going to have to
address
the conversation around the flooding of
the domain and some of those things
yes that's part of a wider picture with
what's going on with the with the
drainage team but certainly it has an
impact in terms of how the reserves in
the domain will be used in the future as
well
so we can make that crystal clear that
the communities come forward with all of
these great plans it wants to fund we're
just looking at how best to allocate the
space
thanks grant andrew and then simon
uh no grant summarized exactly what i
was going to say yeah thanks andrew
did you you had your hand up i believe
no i was just um giving a thumbs up
i need to get my i need to go to spec
savers
my eyes tested
any other
questions from anybody
anybody like to move something
thank you andrew is there a seconder
thank you phillip
all right
any just anything you'd like to say
andrew
no no nothing whatsoever i think the
paper is self-explanatory and um
and uh good to see it underway and i
think the uh
the issue about funding is it is
important even if all the groups so far
have come forward and said they're not
expecting any council funding other than
perhaps the surf club but um
yeah it's a it's a good thing
to to do and there is you can stand you
can see there is potential for
not just expectations but um
uh well maybe that is the right word but
not just financial expectations but
about that use of the land so
it will be whilst i think it's a very
positive thing we might just be careful
to manage
how people perceive it
but that's all part of the consultation
process thank you
now philip did you want to say anything
uh just briefly to say i think it's a
sensible way forward so i'm happy to
second the
recommendation
thanks philip anybody else got anything
they'd like to say
i think you want to say something again
right i'll put that to the vote all
those in favor raise your hand or say i
goes against
it's carried
so thank you very much martin now you've
got your work cut out for you next day
thank you thank you very much everybody
cheers
now i don't know if we want to head to
the workshop with tori so then she can
have the rest of her evening to herself
tori are you there
yes i'm sorry i um
i have a little person here who just
required some help
that's okay do you want to defer do you
want to just um
keep going at your end and we can keep
going with our meeting or
um no you're i'm fine if that's okay
from your end
yeah would just mean then you'd have the
rest of the evening to yourself which
which might be quite nice because grant
tells me he's here till the end
and i i'm having a few technical issues
may end with a second screen so i've
asked here to kindly share her screen
and i'll just speak to it if that's okay
yep that's right and
can you hear me okay it's all good
great thank you
so
thanks thanks for staying on i realize
it's a it's a long night for you and
i'll i have done a powerpoint but it's
really just to
to have some
uh visual maps to look at so it's a
little bit easier to explain but i'll
keep it quite brief so i'll just
quickly run through a little bit of
context
so as you know we're we're here to talk
about the wooden beach domain project
which is the
renewal of the playground and
toilets
in particular tonight it would be really
good for for myself for staff to go away
with
a preferred location
for both the playground
and toilets
so then we can
go away and start planning some
community engagement around that
so i just asked here to go on to the
next page
thanks tia uh just to give a little bit
of context and i i know that you'll be
well aware of where woody and beach
domain is um
but just to
i guess discuss a couple of things to
set the scene
um
it starts in that red circled area there
um as you know uh which is part of the
tuhitara coastal park so i have been out
and spoken to greg burns um and he has
given me
his
preferred
locations and
and ideas which i'll discuss further in
the report
i guess the only other thing on on here
to note is
that
the location of the domain does provide
quite a link to those wider cycle ways
and and walkways um the plexus trail
okay thanks to you
so just to zoom in to to the site um for
some discussion um
so again you'll know where these things
are but we've got the and the blue
circle there the existing location of
the toilet
and the red area we've got the existing
playground
uh the car park stretches
um yeah quite a distance it's sort of um
a hub of the space really um
greg burns has
he's indicated that the trustees are
quite happy with the layout of the
carpark and that as it is
the only problem there is a little um
a few drainage issues
in the green we have the trust office
and in the purple is the
stage which is has recently been
relocated there um
[Music]
the
idea behind the stage i understand is to
be able to hold events
uh in that grass space and encourage
picnicking and things during summer
and greg baines did say that they've had
a couple of events down there
uh he also
talked a bit about how the
grass face on the right of that
cycle walkway path the blue line
is
again a picnic area but it's more of a
relaxed space where people tend to drive
in and
open their car boot and picnic out of
there and um
enjoy that space so he's reluctant to
see that change
um okay here we're going to the next one
so just to discuss the
existing
playground a little uh so we have
in that playground at the moment we have
have a fort
a climbing frame some swings and a
rocking horse
and
as
um
as a reason for having this funding we
have um
95 000
allocated to the renewal of the toilet
um
leading to that
was the identification that it is up for
a neural juicer condition
and
health and safety um
so from from council's perspective
we we are quite keen to see that
playground
replaced and renewed but we'll discuss
that that further
a bit later in the presentation
um
i guess it's worth noting too that the
area is quite boggy and is often
water-lying uh throughout
the whole space really um
[Music]
for that reason i have
spoken to councillors engineers and they
have suggested that
were we to renew the playground it would
be better to raise it at least half a
metre
and that i guess the reasons for that
would would be usability but also the
maintenance cost the ongoing maintenance
costs of having to renew the bark and
the breakdown of the area due to it
constantly being boggy
uh
just on the location plan there i guess
it's it's also
important to note and it has already
been raised by by doug and anna and um
just the
the distance from the playground to the
toilet is
quite vast and i guess
as
a parent of a little one um
[Music]
it can be problematic it's nice you know
to be able to see
um you little ones and if they want to
go as well if you're in a family
situation there
okay yeah i'll get you to move on to the
next one
and this is the location of the toilets
um so
as you can see there
that doesn't have a great
interface
with the carpark side um
and it yeah it definitely does need
renewal um council we have allocated 200
000 towards the renewal of the toilet
block
and
through council's toilet strategy that
would indicate a
four
unit unisex four bay unisex
toilet block um
so we we can discuss that a little
further later on if you like to
uh
it has relatively poor access from the
car park
it is on a mound and doesn't have great
formed access and you sort of have to go
around the back so that's something to
take into consideration
uh and i say it's it's at this point not
associated associated with the
playground well so there's an
opportunity there to improve
okay thanks here
okay so i'm going to jump straight into
some of the location options um which we
can discuss um and i'll just run through
them and then we can come back to them
later if that's all right
so the first one
is
the
preferred option i guess um
by
which doug has raised with you by the
wooden community association uh and that
is to um
not so much to leave the toilets where
they are um
but to renew those um but to leave the
playground
mainly where it is and to make
upgrades and additions to that
um
the
the next option would be
to leave them both in those locations
but to renew both both facilities or
assets
i guess
from staff's
perspective
we can see some some problems with
leaving the playground
in the location that it is
um
as i said we would be looking to
raise the playground um
and that's
really difficult to do while also
leaving
some of the equipment in place um
also if we were to start
leaving things and trying to to fix them
up it doesn't really solve the problem
of of them being of an age where they
need to be renewed
um and we'd have to bring them back to
compliance which is quite a costly
exercise
from a location
idea again it's not ideal having the
playground
the toilet and other facilities like the
car park
and the trust office
all in different locations
we can see some benefit and bringing
that playground closer to the car park
and associates associating it with the
toilet
um
that's
probably enough for that one i'll just
work to the next option thanks to ya
this option uh greg burns has
identified that he he doesn't support
but i just thought it was worth
raising it with use so you can
understand the reasons why not and um
just to know that we have considered
this space as an option
and that is to
move the playground up to where the
existing toilet block is now but with a
new toilet um
toilet building uh so it would be a new
playground and it would be in
a new
location
um
greg burns's
concerns with
us moving it into this the playground or
the play space into this space is
the proximity to the kappa he feels that
there are some safety issues potentially
there
also that it
does take away that relaxed casual
picnic area that i discussed earlier
and he does note that this is
probably one of the wettest areas of the
reserve um
so yeah he's not keen to
see that option go ahead
i'll move on to the
the last option um so option three
is again to
renew both assets um to move the toilet
over towards where the trust office is
there and to move the playground
up um to be closer to the toilet and car
park um to make circulation
a little easier around the space
as i mentioned earlier the stage has now
been relocated into that area and greg
burns is not keen to see
that um
space change
you know he would like to see it
maintain as an area where the events can
be held
and staff are quite supportive of the
shop this option it does bring all the
assets together and um i think it would
be quite
a usable space
okay i'll just
i'm asking to move on here um
so don't be alarmed by these images i'm
i'm not suggesting that
these other play spaces that we would
create or or should create
i'm really just raising some ideas um
as doug and anna raised um that there
are
some other opportunities for
play ideas play equipment play spaces
that we could
do there that um don't have to replace
light for like
you've already raised a half basketball
court which is certainly something that
we could consider um but would probably
be wanting to to engage with the
community and get some ideas of
all the ideas that the community would
like to see and then we'd bring that
back to you
so
um yeah i mean i've just put a
um a little pump track beam extract
there um some swings a slide and um a
few nature play
items it is quite a
a nice natural space and greg burns is
also really keen to see
um some more natural sort of play or
equipment be placed there
i guess the other thing i wanted to note
was
um
that's okay you can leave it on there
that's fine um the other thing i wanted
to note was that i
we did
seek some costs for play equipment if we
were to replace
like with like
and as i say the budget allocated
towards the project is 95 000
but yes for a place like like it came at
came out at around 200 000 um you know
which is well above
budget um
but it may
not be that we need to replace like like
there are some opportunities there to do
potentially some some other
place bases play opportunities
so
uh i've just put the
three well four options up here
and i'll open it up for a bit of
discussion really i'm happy to answer
any questions and um
macleod you're happy to jump in and
answer any questions um as well if you'd
like to
uh yeah i'll leave it to you shona
thanks tori that's great it's a good hit
really good having the photos and and
the aerial shots that actually really
helps a lot so thank you very much for
doing that and for your discussions with
with greg burns because it's good to get
his input because he is there all the
time so he knows where the boggy parts
are shall we say
yeah
phillip you've got a question
yeah dory
who are the likely users of the
playground um
locals or
visitors to the area
with their parents
i'd say a bit of both really um a grant
recount you can jump in here but i um i
wouldn't have necessarily said it was a
it would be a destination play space
it'd be more for um children of the
local area but um
if you've got a different opinion or
grant mccloud have you got any
um
ideas
of course i have an opinion
um
yeah look i i think it's it's relevant
because what this is providing as a play
opportunity not just for people who are
visiting the area but also it's for
local people as well which is what
duggan uh anna i think it was
um had actually mentioned earlier as
well
one of the things that you'll get with a
space like this
people are kind of going to them for a
little bit of a longer visit so for some
of the local kids it's great because
they can actually just jump on their
bike or their horse whichever one it is
that they've got or just their feet
and actually just go exploring and kind
of run around the playground actually
becomes a support mechanism to that
it's not necessarily the main reason
that somebody turns up somewhere but it
certainly provides um
an outlet and a recreational opportunity
for people once they get to a space like
this but it's not going to be the
the playground itself isn't the
destination it's just one of the things
that they'll engage with whilst they're
there
just looking at the location of the
playground and or toilet
the cp whatever design features for
safety
where would they dictate
these facilities should be
and
do you want them
in an open area close to a road access
or do you want them tucked away in a
remote
area
which i could say the existing
playground is in
uh great uh grant again you're welcome
to jump number i would have said um
it would prefer accepted values it would
be better to have them closer to the car
park but
yeah you would definitely bring them
from out the back of the park um because
i guess the the toilet in itself would
not do well in a septet order which is
crime prevention through environmental
design just in case anybody's wondering
um if we would go and do an audit of
that those toilets right now would be
it would probably recommend that those
toilets actually be moved to a more open
area
plus also if we looked at it from an
accessibility perspective it wouldn't do
well through the access group
um i think john's pointed out many times
in the past as well that the doors don't
open that well
so you know it's not ticking a lot of
boxes in its current format
i was actually down there this afternoon
went out and we tripped around this
afternoon um and i saw somebody actually
trying to find their way into the toilet
because as you say it doesn't front the
right way so it is almost quite hidden
um interesting enough there was well i
was there a carload pulled up and it was
two mothers with with four kids
um and they were actually visitors they
rent locals and um
it was quite interesting to watch you
know the boys they went straight for the
playground
interestingly enough a bit of
white court player equipment because it
isn't but what the two girls went for
was actually the stage
and they put on a little performance
while i was there which was quite
fascinating um
so sometimes it's not always what we
think
you know play equipment is
can be quite different for those girls
it was the stage you know they put on a
performance and they were you know they
had great fun with it
um from an accessibility point of view
grant's right that the toilets
and tory the toilets are just completely
inaccessible there is no real path
formed to them
i'd have to say if the playground stayed
where it is raising it up half a metre
makes accessibility just
uh so problematic that
it wouldn't be funny
um
with the
toilets
so you'd be talking about a full bay
unisex would there be any changing rooms
tori
yes so um
i guess that's something
for discussion but when i did seek
prices um
for those
i i did sort of indicate to get an idea
of price that we would want those
cubicles
larger and with a little bench or
something in there so that they could be
used as changing rooms as well but you
don't have to do that it's something
that we can discuss further later
that's fine and
yeah doug had the idea of keeping an
outdoor shower which i know at like
pegasus beach it is extremely well you
use the outdoor shower so
that that's something
right now
can i actually
go mark and then we'll have sandra and
then simon
so on on the other side of the car park
which is where the sound shell used to
be is that part of the domain
could that be somewhere that the toilet
is located
exactly the first question i asked when
i went down there mark it's actually
within the lease for the campground
oh is it
yeah because it's sort of like it's sort
of hard looking at that toilet um
relocation
you you want it sort of somewhere that
people going to the beach can easily use
it to get changed or go to the toilet
and then you want it to the playground
so i was thinking over there would be
but if it's camping ground it's not
going to be but the common ground is
owned by the council anyway isn't it
it's leased out so we don't have rights
to just um
do anything there that we want to it's
it's got to go through a process
um
if i can just say in terms of the
in terms of the toilet location that
tori's proposed it's quite prominent so
it would pick up those people that were
going into the the beach as well
realistically um or what we find a lot
of people like when they're going to an
essay like that is that they actually
just like to know where the immunities
are
um
and so if they can see it as soon as
they can see it uh that's better because
they didn't know that that's available
yep and i mean i just think of it where
it is that pegasus on it's from it's
right by the as you're going to the
beach it's right there in
waikoku beach even though cookie beaches
aren't that good but it's there isn't it
sandra and then simon
thank you um i like option three with
the um luz closer to um
uh to hightail base camp um
seeing they don't have decent toilets
there well they didn't last time i was
there it was um that little shed at the
back
but um i just wondered the the st
location of the stage is that considered
to be
an adjunct to the playground or would
the stage necessarily
need to shift somewhat but shaina said
that
the kids that visited today use the
stage for play
and do those three things work well
together certainly i like the um
certainly option three stands out for me
is is um
ticking all the boxes the only thing
being the um
the position of the stage if you had a
concert there
is it and never well there their kids
playing in the playground that's no
issues
no i think um greg greg was
he was quite supportive of that um
in terms of you know
serving many purposes if if there was an
event on that kids could be using the
playground
at the same time
um
he did raise the possibility that he he
wouldn't be opposed to that access road
being moved a little
to the east i guess um
to allow a little bit more space for the
playground
if we wanted to but um we can get to
that
that stage later but um
yeah
i think you could you could work the
playground in
quite nicely in that space
thank you
good
simon
my question was about
tika haka
being here
is that
is it our understanding that they're
here for the long haul and
um
might they at some point in the future
want additional accommodation
and is that a factor to be born in mind
uh in thinking about this
i'm going to refer to grant for that
to answer that
simon there's there's certainly been
some conversations around what uh greg's
aspirations might be for the for the
future so we'd certainly be talking to
him along those lines throughout this
um
there is no way that we would do
anything down there without his his
input or
potentially being
finding out about something later on
that
might implicate the the design of it as
well so um tori certainly had a lot of
those conversations with greg to make
sure that we're up on the play with what
it is they might be doing um and if
there's any kind of extension or
anything other that they would be
looking at we don't believe
what we're currently proposing would
compromise anything there
[Applause]
andrew and then sandra
okay thanks i think sandra is that you
you messed up sandra's actually before
me but toby
steal your space sandra um just uh two
quick comments uh tori that
that um ability to move the
um
access road i i think um is interesting
because it gives um that really is a bit
of a wasteland now so damp that area off
to the east
and it does would give us some more
flexibility with where those toilets
might be put and give it space
from the um the trust building as well
so i just um like
that that um thought process be extended
more and you know filling in a bit of
that swamp to um create an access world
to my mind is actually kind of a win-win
okay thank you yep i'll definitely look
into that
sandra
we can't hear you muted
i think she was lowering her hand from
it having been raised okay that's fine
i've had i've said everything i
i took my hand down thank you
sorry about that grant you've got your
hand
yeah it's just uh i guess i just want to
address a few of the things that we
heard um earlier in the night just to
make sure that that's that's kind of
fully understood with what it is that um
you know tori's presented here tonight
um
probably one of the key concerns for us
is the accessibility of the current
playground now if we were to raise that
in accordance with what our engineers
have told us there's absolutely no way
that we could keep any of the structural
elements that are within that playground
the other thing that i would say as well
is that with the horse and also with the
fort
we're very unlikely to be able to bring
those up to compliance standards
under
the new playground standards so if we
did any work within there we'd
immediately trigger that
and we'd immediately be
against the guidelines or the the
playground standards so there's not a
lot that we can actually do there to
retain those
um retain those items and trust me i've
had a horse
in an engineering shop for about two
years previously trying to get someone
to redesign one so that we could keep it
and it came back that we had to actually
fix it in place so it ended up just
being a
sculpture which was a bit sad um
but the reality is is that the the kinds
of injuries that we've seen on those
things they've actually purposefully
tried to
design them out of being able to be
retained or put into playgrounds so
that's just something to bear in mind
with that
and hence why tory was kind of
alluding to the fact that you know if we
have to raise it by half a metre it's
there's no way that we can structurally
keep keep any of the current playground
um
in terms of the budget that we've got
we've got 95 and i think that we've
we've heard some really cool ideas uh
tonight but i just wanted to
um i guess put into context without
killing dreams
um just what sort of ninety-five
thousand dollars might look like
um
potentially if you went and put a half
court in we could be looking at anywhere
between sort of 25 to 35 000 dollars
just ballpark
um that's without looking at what cost
inflation in the market is kind of
looking at at the moment
um to put a
uh a flying fox in we know that it's
[Music]
not a similar figure we can kind of be
anywhere from sort of like uh 20 up to
up to 30 plus depending on the geography
that you're actually working with again
really really popular with kits
both of those both of those elements so
i think that's a really good thing to to
be thinking about for the local
community
um it's then what else we can actually
add in to make sure that we're covering
the bases not just for the sort of
destination style play
in terms of everybody kind of coming
down there and enjoying that from more
of a kind of an older youth perspective
and when i say older youth i'm actually
talking sort of nine to 13 year olds for
playgrounds
um
if we were to look at something like a
pump track again they're around about
the they can be around about the sort of
the 15 to 30 000 mark depending on
the materials that you've got to use
what you've got to import and how you
design it
and then looking at the likes of the
spider
spacenet you know that's that's actually
quite a high cost item as well so
just in terms of setting expectations
you're probably going to be able to
afford maybe one or two of those sorts
of elements
um depending on what it is that we've
got to do with groundworks and also kind
of getting the footing and all that sort
of stuff and also raising the playground
as well
so i guess that what i just want the
board to know is that we can investigate
those things bring back some of those
costs
um and i guess kind of let you know uh
what each of those looks like but
sometimes
this might sound a little bit crude but
you can kind of look at a playground
design almost like a smorgasbord where
you're sort of building your own dinner
um or you can go yeah i'm going to have
one of the option a ones i'm going to
have a couple of the option b and then
that will leave us with one for option c
or you might have three from c
one from v and the a
so we've got to make sure that we create
a mix of playground experiences within
there but we've also got to make sure
that we create competitive and
non-competitive spaces as well
um and what i mean by that is exactly
what shona saw today with people being
able to actually break off and do their
own thing
it means that they're actually able to
do that kind of fantasy style play
without necessarily being in the
competitive space of the playground
so
there's a lot of things that actually
kind of go into that and there's a lot
of thinking that tori puts in behind
scenes
around the sorts of things that she'll
propose to you it's not always a case of
going okay what's the budget and how
much space have we got it's actually
looking at it and going how much of that
play value are we actually going to be
putting in here making sure that we've
got the vestibular system development
for the kids
um right the way up to providing a
challenge for the older kids that might
be united sort of that 10 to 13 year old
bracket
13 year olds tend to be on the real
extreme of actually utilizing
playgrounds it's normally that kind of
to be honest by themselves people that
are kind of like gung-ho
it's normally seven up to seven up to
eleven or twelve
um and then different elements like pump
tracks uh half courts that sort of thing
they actually bring a different
demographic to play um and actually a
wider demographic so
just wanted to kind of put some of that
context there because 95 000 might sound
like a lot um but once we get into it
it's actually going to disappear pretty
quick
thanks grant tori what are you doing i'm
trying to be pessimistic
thank you and it's good to actually hear
that tori what are you actually looking
from us
tonight something around the location
and
yes just just to stare on the location
really um and then i we can go away and
do some community engagement on what
we'd like to see in that space
anybody got any preferences we've had
one
is that usandra was it option three
wasn't it
anybody else got any thoughts around
locations
if they can ask a question if the
current playground wasn't raised
so i know it floods but how how
and this year has been an exceptional
year i mean how is it a month a year
that it's normally affected or is it
longer than that
i i'm not a local but i understand it's
um
it's
most of the winter to some degree
but i mean also we have to consider sea
level rise as well which you know i
think the site is only
increasingly going to be wet be a bit
boggy
unfortunately um
so it's sort of looking to the future
and future proofing it really i'm sort
of just thinking if it's raised well
there's not really going to be and
relocated there's going to be no money
for any enhancements from what i can
tell from what grant said so
yeah i guess um
i mean
say that we'd raise it but as grant said
it may end up um
that the community indicate they only
want a couple of
pieces in the end that could be
different for example it could be a
little pump track bmx track um in which
case it wouldn't matter so much
if it was um boggy around the edges it
wouldn't have back which was breaking
down all the time from from being wet
um
we could raise particular areas we need
to if we're putting a slide in or some
swings
yeah i grant you you're welcome to jump
in but um
i think
we can probably design it in a way where
we just raise
areas where required if we need to um
but also yeah have a look a good look at
what we do choose to put in there that
wouldn't be as affected um
by being damp
yeah i i like option three as far as the
toilet is concerned
i'm
a little bit open to where the
playground should be located i think it
needs to be down the carpark end of the
park
um the other thing i wondered was
whether the existing playground
equipment um the wooden sort of rustic
stuff
could just simply be left where it is
um
as grant indicated once you start
upgrading it
you really get rid of it
um so as is leaving it where it is and
having the new playground equipment
further down towards beach road
um an option
i i appreciate what you're um
sort of trying to achieve there
counsellor
the reality is that would definitely
exceed our levels of service in terms of
provision for the area but
probably more concerning is the fact
that
we're well aware of the fact that those
playground pieces and the reason that
we've bought this
in for a renewal
is the fact that they're no longer
compliant under safety standards so the
ideal would be to
have that playground removed
realistically within the next five years
um
when you've got those sorts of elements
you're really kind of looking at it from
a council
staff member perspective to go hey when
is it that we can actually renew that
playground because
we're not entirely happy with the with
the safety performance of it
um
you know ideally we would have it would
have already been renewed by now given
the age of the equipment
so i guess from a greenspace manager
perspective i i would rather see that
that was decommissioned at some point in
the future
thanks grant anybody else got any
preference around location andrea
thank you madam chair um as far as
location um that's indifferent to me the
fact is that we can have a new toilet
and actually enhance our playground then
that surprised me whatever can make it
work as far as financially with the
council that's the prime primary thing
for me so regardless if i can work with
any of the options i'm with that um back
to as far as the pump track um which
tori brought up before and apologize
tori if you're not privileged to
some other
board detail we've had but we've
actually had this raised and i really
resonate with what grant said about not
competing with other areas
and so with the pump
track we've actually had already
communication and a presentation
from
where they would like to actually have a
pump
track there
so
i guess i'm totally grants that grant we
would not have two
there'll be one or the other being so
close proximity
so if we could work together so that one
has it and one doesn't
um but as far as location madam chairs
you're asking um france option mine is
purely just to get
working toilets and a safe playground
for children whether it be one two or
three whatever works for council to make
it happen
thank you for taking my comments
thanks andrea
um
i suppose my
being there today and actually seeing
how it works i mean i'm not there all
the time but just
yeah i know accessibility is a real
issue around playgrounds and toilets um
where the toilets are
is quite inaccessible but still having
the toilets close to the car park i
think
is needed
um
so
you know certainly uh probably option
three is quite good for that
um
playground somewhere around option
three um
because i think having that in close
proximity certainly when i talked to the
two mothers there today they were like
um you know the toilets have to be close
by and i pointed out where they were and
they were like no that's way too far
um
so
and you know i did notice that it was
pretty hard for the you know the mothers
were sort of keeping an eye on the the
girls on the stage way down that end but
they were they were up at the playground
in with the boys so
yeah
it would be nicer to have them closer
together probably
but that's just my thoughts
anybody else got any thoughts
any guidance for tori
that's what she's looking for from us so
i think that's all we're going to get
tori does that help
yeah that's a great help thank you um
yep so we'll go and
um have a good look at that and thank
you we've taken your suggestions on
board so i really appreciate your time
thank you
well thank you thank you for your work
so far and um
i mean these things are a journey we we
know that from from doing playgrounds
previously they are a journey and so
we'll get to know you quite well tori
i'm sure that's great thank you it'll be
a great project
thank you very much
and thank you again doug for your
for your work and it is a journey and we
will work together
and we will
get a good outcome
yes i i just hope that um
you know the the local people can have a
bit of input into things before we go
too far down the track
thanks for that doug
toriel
toriel will definitely wreck with what
she's gotten and um
we will move forward
so thank you very much tori we'll let
you
okay thanks a lot thanks for your time
bye
thanks
but our next report is
section
which is grant
again grant's filling in for
andy coca tonight
yeah no uh
apologies um
but you haven't got andy again uh you've
got me
um
so look what i
want to be quite keen to just point out
with this uh report is that this was
around the consultation we did to
allow the sefton hall committee to
actually be able to move up to
the domain as you recall last year the
committee
as you recall the committee last year
made the decision to
look at relocating the um the hall
itself so they wanted to move up to to
the domain
council has since allocated them two
hundred thousand dollars for seed
funding within um the ltp
where the group are currently at is that
if they can get a license to occupy or i
guess an indication as we've um put
within the recommendations here
uh
that
they can actually start to move forward
with some of their funding plans
what we're also doing to the side of
this as well as the and he's actually
working alongside of the group
and he's going to be taking a more
active role with the group as well uh
in terms of actually getting the
detailed design underway um and you know
kind of getting them prepared for
consenting and that sort of thing
one of the key things for the group um
from my perspective is that they
actually get the support that they need
from us because
they're fulfilling um a council task
as it were and actually meaning that
we're not having to fund the building
and
look you know what they're doing for
their local community is actually really
great and they've
i think they've been a little bit tested
over the last few years just in terms of
going through this process you know it's
not been easy since the quakes
um councillor redmond's obviously been
working with them quite closely on their
uh legal stuff as well so he's well
aware of the amount of hours that
these volunteers have been putting in
and you know when we look at volunteer
burnout it's um
[Music]
it's classic when it comes to meeting
new buildings and stuff like that
because it really takes it out of them
so look what we're proposing here within
the report really as a case of going uh
look we want to give them a license to
occupy for a fixed period of time so
that they can actually have that
security to go and get the detailed
design and so forth in place
now the reason that we're looking at
that is that we want them to be able to
have some flexibility in terms of
getting their design done
because at the moment we don't know how
successful they're going to be with the
quantum of finance that they can
actually get available
so we don't want to make it too big to
the point that they actually then end up
with an area outside of the building
that they're technically responsible for
maintaining
um so there would be some flexibility in
terms of coming back to the board at
some point in the future and actually
going look this is actually the final
design that they've ended up with we'd
like to tighten the lease back down to
that building footprint so that they're
not
uh burdened by having to mow or
responsible for any kind of concrete or
ashfield areas outside of it
um the other thing as well is that we
want to make it crystal clear that we're
not
with what we're proposing here until
they've actually got the funding and the
approval to do the build
we will not be demolishing the current
pavilion
um
so we don't want to go ahead and do that
and then leave cricket in the lurch for
a season or whatever
from them not having that building or
not knowing that it's actually fully
funded and is going to be able to be
delivered
and so look that's really the crux of
what it is that we've put into the
report here and
suggesting it to the community board
so look i'm happy to to take any
questions from that
thanks grant any questions from anyone
i have one question grant which is
around
the the demolition of the uh
current pavilion do you know if there's
any asbestos in that building
uh we have had our buildings uh tested
and examined um off the top of my head i
would need andy's brain to answer that
thoroughly
um if it is that would be taken into
account in terms of us actually removing
the building
that's the other part of this as well is
that we would need to work with the
shifting committee uh in terms of
whether or not we would then demolish
the building ourselves and then leave
them with a clean site to come and build
on
noting that we're still not sure what
quantum of finance they're going to get
yeah that was actually one of my other
questions was around that
it is a council building and
in the report there is the expectation
that the public call committee would
demolish the pavilion
um which would certainly add to their
costs yeah and look i think that it's
it's a fair point that that still um
lies on the table for us to work with
them on how that would be how that would
be approached um again they're
volunteers so there's only so much that
from a staff perspective we can put on
them
any other questions from anyone
hello um grant you know i read this rsl
report
and um if there are next never sorry i
mentioned the rugby club
if they got their own pavilion
uh
there's no rugby club at uh at septon
so yeah
there's there's only cricket cricket and
tennis at the at zefton domain there's
only cricket and tennis
there's no there's no rugby too
rugby papa ashley
now all right
okay
thank you
that's got any other questions from
anybody
philip
thank you madam chair not a question i'm
prepared to move
thank you phillip do i have a second for
that also andrea's got a hand up andrea
what
sorry if you're andrew um
well andrea's just got a hand up but
she's muted and i can't hear her so i'm
not sure
i'm sorry
i'd like to move to a through to h okay
um so philip has moved that so do you
want a second there andrea absolutely
okay
phillip would you like to say something
ah thank you madam chair um it would be
fair to say that the committee are
somewhat frustrated uh
by the delay
and they've been working at this for a
number of years
um i've really only been involved with
trying to move the uh sefton library
forward and that in itself is also a
rather frustrating process
as far as the library was concerned
which is going to be hopefully part of
their funding
um a leader was sent to crown law with
the proposals to vary the trust it took
six months to get a reply from crown law
which came through about a week ago
so there are one or two amendments that
have to be made but things are obviously
going very slowly for them so i do try
and encourage them to keep and hang in
there and
they're doing that so far so i see this
as moving things forward and they will
have some positive
progress so very happy to support it
thank you phillip andrea anything you'd
like to say
um only that if anything out of being on
this board for the last two terms if i
can see this getting over the line then
i think i've done
something
with our board
because we have worked with them
ardently trying to get this across the
line
and like grant said they're a quite
exceptional group
that are willing to do so much work on
their own without the assistance of
council only probably for advisement
and also for the lease of land i
appreciate that but crikey i'm pretty
proud of what an amazing area they are
that they've done so much mahi
um
on their own and i'm proud if we can
push them across the line and get it
done and that's just my little input but
thank you to you
thanks andrea well sid
anybody else got anything to add
um i would just like to throw my support
fully behind it um
just with that concern noted around the
the demolition of the existing pavilion
and certainly the the whole committee
have
yeah you know they really have
worked really hard and i would like to
thank um council uh particularly grant
for
for for
loaning them andy is it ruined his
expertise to actually help them because
that is something we we did ask for um
in a couple of annual plan um
submissions and it's good that that you
know council has provided that
assistance and andy will be andy coco
will be great working with them
and it is what they need is to actually
have somebody working alongside with
them so i'm absolutely thrilled about
that
anybody ask anything to add
right i'll put that to the vote
um a through to h
all those in favor say i'll raise your
hand
anyone against
that's carrie thank you very much thanks
grant that um
green space has done very well tonight
thank you very much
yeah
yeah thank you we've uh we've enjoyed
our time with you
well done grant
[Music]
thank you so much right we have got
three
discretionary grant applications andrea
has indicated that she will sit out for
the one on the pegasus residence group
because she is a member of that group
um
so actually
there is no conflict of interest because
she is the board's appointment to the
pegasus
she isn't she is actually on the
committee on the
uh i'm sorry though
so so i think we'll probably take them
individually is going to be easier do
you want to start with the
replacement battery
for the default thanks tia anything
you'd like to tell us about that one um
through you madam chair the pegasus
resistance group is applying on behalf
of the residents of the cuckoo beach
for
funding for a replacement of the aeg
battery that is used by the community
and um i'm happy to answer any questions
thanks claire anybody got any questions
around that one
all right
i would like to move that we fund
actually 635 dollars for the replacement
battery which is above the 500
but we do have money in the
discretionary fund and i would um like
to recommend that we
we uh pay the 635 dollars it is safety
equipment um and this has been
[Music]
for a number of reasons going on for
some time
um yeah do i have a seconder for that
i second it
we've got everybody wanting to second it
had your hand up so
you're it
philip would you like to say something
uh no just to say i think it's a good
use of funds the person who obviously
donated
i think it was the derma
derma scopey center if i'm recalling
right um they're paying for some of the
consumables
so um
it seems a good use of our funds to do
the battery
thanks for that andrew anything you'd
like to say use your hand up before
no
anybody else right i'll put that one to
the vote all those in favor of 635 for
that one say i'll put your hand up
hi
those are kids
that's carried
welcome back andrea you can come back in
now right we've got the wooden netball
club
through you madam chair the wooden
netball club has grown substantially
with the new developments of rangiora
and um also in pegasus and they now have
approximately 150 players they are
asking for a new goal posts
that would allow them to actually have
two courts where the players can play on
the gold course has got two rings that
allows basically for junior and for
senior players to be able to use them
i'm happy to take any questions
any questions for tia
no somebody like to move something
andrew
john
john you'll move
yeah i'll move about i think they sit
down
b to the native the 500 they're asking
for
thank you john dover secondary is that
you andrew
i'll second that oh okay
andrew's secondly john anything you'd
like to say
i know i just think it's a um
a really good use of funds
thanks for that john
andrew anything you'd like to add
anything from anybody else
um yeah fully in support myself so
um i'll put that to the vote all those
in favor say aye or raise your hand
goes against
that's carried and we have rinnell's
community kappa
tia thank you thank you madam chi i'm
sure everybody has been to one of these
cuppers they're quite enjoyable and the
cake is yum yum
and um there's a lot of people that
actually goes to these kappas and it's a
great community event that's been active
in the community for
a few years and i'm happy to answer any
questions
that members may have
any questions for tia
anybody like to move something
philip
um i'll move that we provide a grant of
500.
for rene's community copper
you just like the cake don't you phillip
all right do i have a second for that
thank you john yep yep
hello
other than the cake anything you'd like
to say
uh well thank you madam chair i don't
get i do try and make an effort to go to
these but i get to go to about one and
every three or four um i find them very
well attended and it does engender
community spirit and overcome isolation
and uh ronald herself who i've got to
know is sort of a legend in her own
lifetime
so it's a very good well-run event and
for 500 you're getting good bang for
buck
[Music]
um
john anything you'd like to add
no that's i think there's a good use of
bones
anybody else got anything to say
um unfortunately i want to go against
the 500 and i'm happy to have it
recorded as well
they've received the last two years 500
um
from us as a board and this year i
decided not to to go for that purely
because we've already outlaid already
twice tonight with other
entities that haven't asked for those
particular things so i'm happy to have a
recorded that i
do not vote
for 500 towards the rinau's cuppa thank
you thanks andrea um i would like to say
that i will be supporting it i am
actually in a a quite a regular attendee
of the community kappa um
often tend to speak to just update um
people on what is happening either at
council level what consultations are
around and a community board level
um
certainly the mayor attended the last
one and was very well received um
one before that was actually the annual
plan
drop-in
they did
the planners came along and did a
session and it was extremely well
received uh
it certainly does mean there isn't a
more engaged community
um and
um
the socialization is quite amazing um i
think
the last one i think there was six new
people um attended who hadn't attended
before which was pretty amazing
um
and i think this funding just allows
them time to actually get established as
them themselves away from the pegasus
residence group
and actually find a way of the funding
going forward so i will be supporting it
anybody else got anything to add
all right i'll put those back to the
vote all those in favor say aye or raise
your hand
those against
andrea
anybody else
okay so andrea said you'd like that
recorded
um
so that will be recorded so that is
carried thank you very much everybody
thank you tia
um i would actually like to say that um
all three
um
you know uh applications particularly
the the woody netball and ronald's cuppa
were
so much detail and uh it was they were
fantastic applications
right
we've got the reticle where is my agenda
what are we up to so go back to my
beginning
right so we've got the ratification of
the community board submission to the uh
annual draft annual plans for the
waimakariri district council and ecan
tia anything you'd like to add to that
um no thank you madam chair i will take
the reporters red
thanks
any questions from anyone
i'd just like to make a comment
i i thought they really well presented
submissions
i really
enjoyed reading them okay that's all i
wanted to say
thanks matt phillip
uh could i just declare an interest in
the
submission to the council
because i may very well be deliberating
on your submission
so i'll take no part in that discussion
or vote
thank you for that philip
now do i have a mover
um to move
ratification of those two submissions
thank you john
um i'll second that john anything you
you've already made a comment anything
else you'd like to say
no that's that's all i wanted to say
thank you for that
um i've really got anything to say
anybody ask anything to add
right i'll put that to the vote all
those in favor say aye
raise your hand
goes against
that's carried
an abstention from me yes
correspondence we had the update on my
walking and cycling network plan
consultation
which has been delayed
any questions around that
anything you'd like to add tia
i'm sorry madam chair only comment is um
frustration at the delay
um and that's just personally from me
as a board member and also as a cyclist
um that this has been ongoing
thing that has been gone on too long
and i appreciate there's been a change
of staff and
and those have been hitting the project
but um i surely would have thought that
would earn some positive outcome by now
and i'm happy to have that noted
now just comment on what andrea said um
uh just bear in mind that this
consultation um the
the money um for the project is some
years out so i mean um while i
uh it was actually me that asked um ali
and
uh where it was because the last i um
noted was it was going to be consulted
on in in february but what um and it's a
function of covert and stuff
the usual stuff
but
we need to remember that and this
consultation needs to have it um
front and center is that the money
for any of these works is some some
years off
thank you
thanks alexandra
anybody else got anything
can somebody move something for me that
we received
the memo
i'll move that we receive it do i have a
seconder
thank you sandra
anybody got anything else i'd like to
add
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say i
i'll raise your hand
those against
that's carried
chairperson's report i'll take that as
read any questions around that
uh i will move that that report is
accepted as received do i have a
seconder for that
thanks john
anybody got anything to add
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye i'll raise your hand
goes against that's carried
matters for information are listed there
anybody got any questions around those
i will move that we receive those do i
have a seconder for that
thank you andrew
anybody got anything they'd like to say
to that
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor say aye or raise your hand
goes against
that's carried
right we have a public excluded report
did everybody receive that
now do i have to go to public excluded
to
pass this tear no that's good
right i'd like to move that uh the
recommendation that we received the uh
report
and uh and that it remained public
excluded
uh do i have a seconder for that
thank you andrew
anybody got anything to say
i'll put that to the vote all those in
favor raise your hand or say i
goes against
that's carried
right members information exchange this
is the time where quarter past day
anybody need a quick break were you okay
to just finish this off
we'll keep moving then
um
all right andrea
members information exchange anything
you'd like to share with us only thing
is i've resigned from um north
canterbury neighborhood sport as the
chair
yeah um
so
that's been that will be hand over to
someone else but um
i won't go into tonight but there's a
reason for me resigning from it
and so um disappointingly that's where
i'm at with that there as well
so thank you though
well thanks andrea
john
you got anything you'd like to tell us
you've been up to
john
you're on mute
yes we can okay
um
everything i've attended this
month has been on um
[Music]
first one was with the
pegasus by
my law
and it was on a
platform i've never come across before
and it was some microphone something
anyway um
we kept on getting interruptions on the
on the court you know what was happening
because my hearing aids
were upsetting the balance i couldn't
believe it so anyway i've had
a meeting with the woody and community
association on zoom
i've had the
northern drainage board or the greatest
thing i belong to
um on the zoom
and now i've had the
williams septon community board on zoom
so i feel pretty soon out
okay
hello
i've been away but preoccupied with
other things so i don't have a written
report
i can say creative communities are
currently considering applications we've
had 22 applications for art type grants
and the committee
will be assessing those later this week
so um that's a good number compared with
the previous round when we had about six
so i've been busy doing other things but
didn't get to uh
recall at all
so that's it for me
thanks phillip i did have cake at
ronald's i'll declare that
you did
um andrew
nothing
so was there anything out of that uh
pegasus bay bylaw
meeting
um yes there was uh the most uh
significant interesting thing was
some
engagement with
the
ministry of fisheries effectively
regarding their claims
and shellfish on the beach so
we um the ministry of fisheries is going
through a
process to look at um
quota and what's and and such like and
part of that is to decide what's
actually out there so
it's a good thing for us to do as a
group to be involved in that and get
some facts together
um so we know where we stand
in considering the some of the matters
along the beach there so um so that
engagement has happened it's um
coincides with their process and bloody
love all that sort of thing so so that's
good i think it was a very good um and
very timely
um the thing to come from but the review
is happening sometime
i can't remember the exact date but it's
it's this it will happen this year
because it was delayed from last year
and i can't recall anything else
significant from that
i was there obviously
thanks for that andrew
sandra have you got anything to add
um three things um
uh the zone committee allocated its
fifty thousand dollar annual grant um
and there are three projects that are
within
this area
there's
enonga spawning enhancement in the
taranaki stream
and i think that's underway it's got
even more funding there's a stoney creek
saltwater creek catchment group that has
um got got some money um to uh
that's mainly farmer focus but it would
probably be um a good idea if someone
local um
put their hand up to
at least have a watching brief on it um
carolyn nathan uh
has um as a zone committee member
um is sort of
well well the instigator of the um
of the group the other thing is the um
the pines wetland um
uh in in in tuhitara park um got a hunk
of money to for willow
removal
the second thing
the
alpine river section of the canterbury
land and water regional plan which
is the section yet still to be reviewed
by environment canterbury and
concerns um the minimum flow in the
waimakariri river
and as a result of that
the salt saltwater intrusion at the
kaiapoi river
um
that is not going to go ahead because um
iken is now fully involved with doing
updating the entire canterbury land and
water regional plan to get a
notification out in 2024.
um i'm a bit concerned and i was going
to ask simon um markham how we um
how is a
council
get involved in this because we would
have been
ideally submitting on that chapter which
is now not going to be
reviewed but
married into the whole big exercise
that they're trying to get out um
so i can ask
simon that and the third thing is the um
the ashley rangiora reach
um of
replanting
that fits into the whole braided river
revival of the ashley that
ecan's underway with
unfortunately they seem to be doing it
in a bit of a piecemeal basis and i
don't know whether
whether any of you were involved in the
april 7th ecan consultation on the rangi
aura reach that
that
came about because they without
notification of anybody felt all those
trees and got everybody up everybody's
nose but
so they're consulting on that um
that reach
um
restoration
but the zone committee's um quite
concerned that the overall picture of
how that fits into the braided river
revival
isn't quite clear
but um
i'm i'm hoping that some of you were
involved in that um
rangiora reach um
because it's um
in your in our patch i think
yep
so that's me
mark
um no i don't have anything did you get
that list sort of those street names
from john harris so i didn't give any
feedback for you
no i'll talk about that later i think
mark
anything else
no not really
sandra i think that that review has been
outstanding for a very long period of
time hasn't it
for the alpine
oh yes it was the last chapter to be
reviewed after uh pc7 um and of course
yeah we were interested in
well when i say we the kaiapoi
councillors were interested because it
has material significance for the club
but they they told us it was a separate
section and it was the last chapter to
be reviewed but now
it's going to be
come married in with the whole
okay so
we we're still really concerned about
how do we get our input into that
particular
section or issue
sure look i'll not take more time
tonight maybe we can take this offline
heavy to follow it up because
um uh yeah just what's the basis of the
review and
um
how long how much longer if you like
well i don't think they're doing it i
think it does no no
the issue ultimately in terms of flow
regime still
still needs to get addressed so yeah so
what's the process yeah got it okay i'll
i'll follow that up
thanks simon anything else simon
no sorry that's me
right current consultation projects we
have migrant
experiences um probably also worthwhile
if you're involved with any groups just
telling them about the uh walking and
cycling
network plan that you know the delay but
it is coming and to start
thinking about it and to get their
feedback in when it does
we've spent some money for a
discretionary grant tonight so that's
good it's dropped the balance a little
bit
our general landscaping fund is
fully committed
for this year
and that's actually something the board
could consider for next year is perhaps
um putting some money towards uh some
planting
uh if the uh hedge is removed at waikoku
beach i mean we could put some money
from
our funding grant towards that
in the next year
that's something anything anybody would
particularly like me to focus on in the
media or just a round up from
tonight
the um
the funding sweaty
yep we'll do not a problem
we haven't
actually in china pro recognizing that
we have uh recognizing the issues that
were raised in community for
waikoku
beach
with the hedging
and also with um would end with the
playground and stuff of that probably
just recognizing that not giving them
answers but just recognizing that is
actually tabled and we're actually
communicating over that so that would be
quite constructive yeah
thank you very much
right we don't have any questions
understanding orders we don't have any
urgent general business understanding
orders our next meeting is on the 9th of
may
which is probably also likely to be
zoomed by the sound of it
so officially i would like to
close the
meeting
and
[Music]